>>> THE CASE OF A MISSING
MASSACHUSETTS WOMAN HAS GOTTEN
MORE DISTURBING.
PROSECUTORS NOW SAY THAT BLOOD
AND A KNIFE WERE FOUND IN THE
BASEMENT OF ANNA WALSHE'S HOME.
WALSHE WAS LAST SEEN EARLY ON
NEW YEAR'S DAY AND WAS REPORTED
MISSING ON WEDNESDAY.
THIS NEW INFORMATION CAME DURING
A HEARING JUST A SHORT TIME AGO
FOR HER HUSBAND.
BRIAN WALSHE IS CHARGED WITH
MISLEADING INVESTIGATORS, AND
CNN HAS MORE ON THE DETAILS.
SO A LOT HAS COME OUT TODAY.
GET US UP TO SPEED ON THE
LATEST.
>> Reporter: YEAH, SO THE
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
THERE IN NORFOLK COUNTY LAYING
OUT THE INSTANCES WHERE THEY SAY
BRIAN WALSHE LIED ABOUT HIS
WHEREABOUTS SURROUNDING THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF HIS WIFE, ANA
WALSHE, AROUND NEW YEAR'S DAY.
NOW IF I COULD BACK UP FOR A
SECOND FOR YOUR VIEWERS AND
EXPLAIN THAT BRIAN WALSHE WAS
ACTUALLY ON PRO-PROBATION
SENTENCING FOR A FRAUD INCIDENT
THAT GOES BACK TO 2020.
HE PLED GUILTY TO.
AS PART OF THAT HE WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE CHECKING IN WITH
AUTHORITIES ON HIS WHEREABOUTS.
SEEMS THAT THAT'S HOW
INVESTIGATORS WERE ABLE TO TELL
THAT HE WAS LYING ABOUT THOSE
WHEREABOUTS.
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
INSTANCES THAT CAME OUT IN
COURT, BUT ONE THAT STICKS OUT
IS HE TOLD INVESTIGATORS THAT HE
WAS GOING TO TAKE ONE OF HIS
SONS OUT FOR ICE-CREAM AND
INSTEAD IT APPEARS HE WENT TO A
HOME DEPOT.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR FROM THE
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS DOING THERE.
>> HE'S ON SURVEILLANCE AT THAT
TIME PURCHASING ABOUT $450 WORTH
OF CLEANING SUPPLIES, THAT WOULD
INCLUDE MOPS, BUCKET, TOPS,
TVEX, DROP CLOTHS, AS WELL AS
VARIOUS KINDS OF TAPE.
>> Reporter: AND ACTUALLY WE GOT
THE CRIMINAL COMPLAINT FROM THAT
COURT HEARING, AND IT GOES INTO
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THAT VISIT TO
HOME DEPOT.
IT SAYS THAT HE WAS WEARING A
BLACK SURGICAL MASK, A BLUE
SURGICAL GLOVES, AND MAKING A
CASH PURCHASE.
AS YOU HEARD, $450 WORTH OF
CLEANING SUPPLIES.
ALSO MENTIONED A BLOODY KNIFE
FOUND IN THE BASEMENT AS WELL AS
BLOOD STAINS.
HE'S NOT TIED TO THE MURDER YET,
BUT A LOT COMING OUT IN COURT.
HE IS BEING HELD BEHIND BARS AND
WILL BE BACK IN COURT ON THIS
PARTICULAR CHARGE AT LEAST IN
FEBRUARY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
UPDATE.
LET'S SPEAK NOW TO FORMER SENIOR
FBI PROFILER AND FORMER FBI
SPECIAL AGENT MARY ELLEN
O'TOOLE.
SO NEW DETAILS WE JUST GOT IN
COURT.
HE BOUGHT $450 IN CLEANING
SUPPLIES THE DAY AFTER SHE
DISAPP
DISAPPEARED AND A KNIFE WITH
BLOOD ON IT WAS FOUND.
I WONDER, INNOCENT IT WILL
PROVEN GUILTY BUT YOU'RE A
PROFILER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DETAILS,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION.
>> THAT WOULD ELEVATE ANY
INTEREST IN THE HUSBAND AND OF
COURSE ALL OF THAT PHYSICAL
EVIDENCE WOULD HAVE TO BE
ANALYZED TO CONFIRM THAT IT IS
HER BLOOD ON THE KNIFE AND
CLEANING SUPPLIES ARE OFTEN USED
IN CASES AND PEOPLE THINK THAT
THEY COULD CLEAN UP BLOOD OR
OTHER PHYSICAL EVIDENCE THAT IS
LEFT BEHIND.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
SO IF THEY CAN CONFIRM THAT THEY
DO HAVE A SCENE, THEY HAVE A
SCENE WHERE SHE WAS HURT OR
MURDER AND THEY COULD CONFIRM IT
IS HER, THEN THAT CERTAINLY
ELEVATES THE INTEREST IN HIM.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE ODD HERE.
SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO RETURN TO
WORK ON JANUARY 3rd BUT
APPARENTLY THERE WAS A WORK
EMERGENCY AND THAT IS WHY SHE
WAS GOING BACK TO WASHINGTON,
D.C., SUPPOSED TO GO EARLIER.
AND THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT SHE ACTUALLY GOT
IN A RIDE SHARE CAR EARLY MINUTE
MORNING ON THE FIRST TO GO TO
THE AIRPORT.
AUTHORITIES AREN'T REALLY
CONFIRMED THAT DETAIL.
DOES THAT STRIKE YOU AS
SURPRISING?
>> IT STRIKES ME AS SURPRISING
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO,
IF IT OCCURRED, THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CONFIRM THE UBER OR THE
TAXI OR SOME OTHER RIDE SHARE
THAT PICKED HER UP.
SO THEY PROBABLY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION.
BUT THEY'RE NOT RELEASING IT.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE EASY TO
CONFIRM.
>> TELL US ABOUT NEXT STEPS IN
AN INVESTIGATION LIKE THIS?
WHAT WILL THEY DO WITH REGARDS
TO BOTH THE HUSBAND HERE, BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF INVESTIGATING
THE DISAPPEARANCE ITSELF.
>> WELL ONE OF THE PRIORITIES IS
OBVIOUSLY TO TRY TO FIND -- IF
SHE'S DEAD TO TRY TO FIND HER
BODY AND THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
THAT.
BUT IT IS A PRETTY DIFFICULT
SITUATION TO JUST HAVE SEARCHERS
OUT THERE WITH DOGS TRYING TO
LOOK IN A LOCATION WHERE A HUMAN
BODY MAY OR MAY NOT BE.
SO, PROBABLY AT THIS POINT, WHAT
THEY'RE DOING, IF HE'S NOT
TALKING TO THEM, IS THEY'RE
TALKING TO OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
CLOSE TO THE FAMILY, OTHER
PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE OTHER
INFORMATION AND, OF COURSE, IF
THE HUSBAND HAS TRANSPORTED HER
SOMEPLACE, THEY'LL BE SEARCHING
THE CAR FOR ALL SORTS OF
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE.
>> STILL SO MANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS POINT.
MARY ELLEN O'TOOLE, APPRECIATE
YOUR INSIGHT.
THANK YOU.